meet Sarah Sarah is a sales professional
and a tungle me user when she wants to
meet with clients she turns to tungle me
because with tungle me there are no
costly double bookings no time zone
mishaps and no more email ping pong
trying to find a time that works for
everyone here's how it
works John is Sarah's client Sarah
emails him the details of an upcoming
project he wants to book a call to
discuss
so he clicks the tungl me link in
Sarah's email signature he arrives at
her tungl me page to see the times when
she is free he clicks to schedule the
meeting adds details selects a few
available times and
sends Sarah receives the email
invitation she sees the times John has
proposed overlaid on her own
calendar she picks a time that works and
clicks book meeting the meeting is
automatically added to Sarah's calendar
and John receives an email confirmation
to add to his
calendar it's as simple as
that Sarah's tongel me page only
displays times that she wants shown is
available she has set her availability
for mornings and afternoons every Monday
to
Thursday she is also sync tongle me with
her calendar so that as new events are
added to her calendar tungl me will
automatically ially update her
availability and she won't be double
booked when Sarah wants to meet with
others she uses tungl me to send private
meeting invitations that propos multiple
times she can send them to one or many
people and they can reply with times
that work for them without ever signing
up what else can Sarah do with tungle
she can add a photo contact info and
links to her website and social
profiles customize her page and meeting
invitation with her company logo and
colors share her URL in her email
signature over Skype through Twitter on
LinkedIn and even printed on her
business
cards schedule group meetings by
proposing multiple times and viewing
everyone's replies
overlaid and schedule from her iPhone
Blackberry or
Android and that's how tungl me makes
scheduling meetings quick and easy for
Sarah so are you ready to tongle